Here's another error that many people make. Remember what our goal was? Our
goal was that our balance should be bigger than the target. So lots of people,
when they write their while loop, they put that goal, which they have firmly in
their mind, into the header of the loop. But that's not how the while loop
works. The while loop says I want to stay in the loop while the condition is
fulfilled, and that's exactly the opposite of the goal. That's a common
confusion. I'll let you fix it in just a minute, but here's how I remember it.
Look at the board, little girl there. And she's warning, are we there yet? Have
I reached my goal, namely to be at the destination? And while loops are not
like little girls, they're the exact opposite. They're excited to be going and
going and going, so you want to formulate your goal while there's still work to
be done, we can do it. You'll get a chance to fix this bug right now.